[Applause]
[Music]
protest around statues have been one of
many
polarizing moments for americans and for
the rest of the world
and i promise we'll get to that but
first let's talk about breakups
[Music]
for a lot of people out there who've
spent a significant amount of time with
someone
only to have it and badly a common
cathartic process
is removing any imagery that reminds you
of them whether it's a gift they gave
you or a trinket or
actual photographs and today it's never
been easier
companies like adobe and apple make it
part of their advertising campaigns
we all engage in some level of editing
our own history
we remember the good parts maybe forget
the bad parts
but when this happens on a societal
scale things become
much more complicated especially when
some people feel as if they're the ones
being
erased and when it comes to say
destroying art
well we've been doing that since the
beginning of recorded history
as long as we've been making art we've
been destroying it
that's professor aaron thompson of john
jay college of criminal justice
and i'm an expert in the deliberate
destruction of art and art crime in
general
as long as someone has thought someone
is great enough to make a statue up
someone else has come along and thought
nope we're tearing that down that person
isn't great at all
i think of the egyptians sculpting
statues of themselves to last for
eternity to put in their tombs for many
egyptians
eternity didn't last forever especially
when it came to their noses
the most common question that
egyptologists are
asked why are the noses broken on
ancient egyptian art
research done by this man edward
bleiberg shows that this damage wasn't
done by the long march of time
rather it was a very specific practice
called iconoclasm
this is the act of attacking established
values and institutions
through destroying symbols attacking a
statue
is somewhere deep in the human brain
something like
attacking that person themselves in
egyptian mythology
statues were thought of as spiritual
vessels so removing a nose
was a way to disable that connection to
the afterlife but blyberg also theorizes
about another culprit for this
destruction
early christian monks every new society
when it's creating
destroys images of the past
you see the same thing happening in the
french revolution
with the overthrow of the aristocratic
government of france
there was also an overthrow of statues
this is a cyclical process and it's
happened countless times throughout
history
once a society rises it builds statues
to represent itself
and then as a new society comes along it
removes or destroys those old statues
and replaces them with their own an
example of that cycle on a shorter
timeline
are the christopher columbus statues
across the united states
statues of columbus are fascinating to
me because they were
put up at a time when italians were not
necessarily considered white when
whiteness was something that was
northern european statues of columbus
were
funded by italian-american groups as a
part of an argument that we
are italian-american don't reject us
don't discriminate against us
now statues of columbus are being
protested by native americans who see
columbus as a symbol
of the fact that they are excluded from
belonging to america
and while the facts around columbus as a
man remain problematic
as a symbol he simultaneously stands for
mass genocide to some
and national pride to others
what these heritage sites and places
statues and
and historic buildings do is they give
us a
tangible sense of the intangible this is
professor laura jane smith
she spent her career researching
studying and writing about heritage and
its effects on society
including a decade-long study and how we
interact with heritage sites
most people go to reinforce what they
already know feel and believe
and this is one of the issues with the
heritage debate is that we have this
sort of sense that
we heritage particularly national
heritage
has to make us feel good and feel good
about ourselves
and when we visit these sites to
reinforce our deeply held beliefs
it can blind us to realities right under
our noses
smith pointed to a series of interviews
she conducted at andrew jackson's
hermitage in tennessee where visitors
had to walk through an
exhibit on the former president's role
in slavery before they could enter his
palatial plantation house
visitors engaged in an array of
responses that
attempted to shield themselves from the
from the
negative emotions that cut into their
sense of comfort for visiting the pres
this presidential house
some people would say when i asked them
what did you think of the exhibition
would say what exhibition i didn't
notice
any exhibition so intent were they to
get to the comforting presidential
performance
others would go oh yes i saw it but i'm
not in you know it's not relevant
it's not relevant to this to this
history i've come to see
jackson while it may be natural for many
of us to avoid engaging with the more
complicated parts of our history these
public forms of art
are having an impact on us as a society
neuroscientists talk about the halo
effect and i like to talk about
the pedestal effect
when we see someone up on a pedestal all
these assumptions kick in that they must
be someone who's there to be respected
to be praised to be honored
so statues are very bad at communicating
nuance and shades of gray
they are what michael billig has
referred to as a form of banal
nationalism
they are so ubiquitous that we tend to
forget that they're there but
nonetheless are constantly referencing
and representing particular ideas and
and
group identity and so on identity is
complicated it's
much easier to think of america as a set
of almost like flashes of images of
the flag and the statue of liberty not a
portrait of washington
and that is a shorthand for what it
means to be an american
so if you change those images that
changes identity images
summarize complex things and if we want
to change complex things sometimes we
need to change those summary images
when we're not fighting actual wars we
often fight wars by using images
by attacking the idea of what the other
side is standing for
to say i don't want a white supremacist
america anymore you attack statues that
represent a white supremacist america
but watching these images change in real
time is much different than walking
through an
ancient iconoclasm exhibit in a museum
while removing or reclaiming a statue
can give some that same cathartic sense
as removing an ex from a photo
for others it feels like a personal
attack
not only on their past but their future
if you don't
pay attention to history it repeats
itself through history people have been
horrified by the destruction
of statues because that's a sign of our
fragility that not only our bodies but
our whole legacy
any memory of us could be overthrown
disrespected
disregarded so to defend a statue
of really anybody is to defend this idea
that you
yourself might be around for the future
heritage
and history are constant processes of
reassessing who we are
and who we want to be debate will always
be ongoing
and that that in itself is i think a far
more healthy and constructive
way of approaching both heritage and
history